[Music]
it was rumored actually that Madonna
could have played listen to this Vivian
and pretty woman which is so crazy to
think about anyone other than Julia
Roberts in that role but that is exactly
what's happening on Broadway right now
and we were with the actors adding new
voices to the iconic duo
obviously all version is dramatically
different to begin with because there's
music and we sing so how do you
translate what just might be the most
beloved romantic comedy ever for the
stage well first you need the look
Samantha barks plays Vivian while Andy
Carl takes on the role of Edward check
out their near-identical recreation of
the movie poster I think I worth by five
different weeks and a lot of you know a
lot of makeup makeup changes a lot of
costume changes and Samantha got Julia's
approval earlier this month when she saw
the show great new boots
oh it's a choice it's a fashion choice
it's Sam
miss Vivian julia was wearing that
iconic outfit when et visited the set of
the movie in 1989
she's prostitute you know essentially
and it wouldn't be pretty woman without
that red dress and jewelry box
other movies coming to Broadway get
ready people beetlejuice Moulin Rouge
and The Devil Wears Prada with music
written by Elton John gotta get back I'm
ready right
[Music]